the ever deadpan ory Plaza might be on
course to stir up some trouble in Agatha
hna's darkhold Diaries but she's no
stranger to the Marvel Universe back in
2017 ory Plaza caused chaos in the
Effect series Legion as Lenny Busker and
the Shadow King am Farooq and was a
force to be reckoned with around the
same time there was another corner of
the comic book world she had an eye on
but unfortunately didn't get the chance
to play around in it involved sharing
the screen with none other than Wade
Wilson in his swey sequel Deadpool 2 had
things gone to plan it would have been
Plaza's second stint in the world of
mutants after the TV show which focuses
on Charles Xavier son